This video is brought to you by movie.
Get 30 days for free by going to movie.com/now you see it
like many other franchises and ensemble films.
The X-Men series had the challenge of juggling several character arcs while
still maintaining a story that spans over multiple films. In fact,
the biggest influence on the X-Men sequel [inaudible] was another SQL from
another huge franchise. You may have heard of it.
The production team referred to X two as the X men equivalent to the star Wars
sequel, the empire strikes back.
Both films made established characters split apart and come to their own
realizations X two effectively adapted this concept for its own characters,
film and film series, and the scene that best captures how the film executes.
This idea is one exceed here and the X-Men infiltrate the oval office to warn
the president of the coming war. In the third X-Men film.
The scene takes place after Stryker tried to brainwash Xavier and to using his
powers to wipe out all mutants.
Xavier tells the president what happened and reminds him that the mutants aren't
going anywhere and in the future,
humans and mutants need to work together to bring peace.
Mr. President, the next move is yours.
At first glance. The scene may seem like just an easy way to set up the SQL,
but it's actually packed with an impressive amount of depth,
finishing up several character arcs and summing up the movie itself all while
looking awesome.
So let's take a look at how this excellent scene gives closure to the struggles
of multiple characters in the film and addresses the main theme of the entire
X-Men franchise.
This time of adversity, we are being offered in moments.
Before we even see any X-Men in this scene,
we get hints that multiple mutants are about to show up.
First, we see lightning and hear thunder,
and we instantly know it's not just bad weather.
It's the mutans storm storms powers always signal her arrival before we see her.
And it reminds us of an earlier moment in the film when she did the exact same
thing, then the president notices everyone is frozen in place.
So we now know Xavier is involved too,
because everybody freezing reminds the viewer of a similar moment in the
beginning of the film. So before we even see the mutans,
the visuals of the scene, prime,
the viewer for the Epic payoff of the team appearing in the oval office.
Good morning, Mr. Perez.
And the combination of freezing characters and using lightning creates an
amazing image, but the final scene goes beyond cool visuals.
The dialogue is actually extremely multilayer for such a seemingly simple scene.
It's filled with character pails that neatly tie up the events of the film for
Logan. Xavier speech makes him empathize with Cyclops.
And there have been casualties losses on both sides.
And they sort of come to terms with each other in the next scene.
And he also got another more subtle moment throughout the film.
There's a recurring theme that Logan abandons people.
You'll be here when we get back, unless you plan on running off again,
I can be the good guy, good guy sticks around.
And he later fulfills this prophecy where's Logan.
But in the end.
He rejects that past self and embraces his role in the X-Men.
By the time he's at the white house, he completes this character arc.
When he gets aligned, saying, he'll stick around.
We'll be watching.
Similarly Xavier's dialogue also calls back to his actions in the film in this
scene,
the X-Men give the president files that show Stryker was trying to kill all the
mutants.
How'd you get this? Well, that's just say,
I know a little girl who can walk through walls.
With such a diverse group of superheroes.
There were tons of ways for saving your ticket. Those files.
I think the writers wanted [inaudible] to have the little girl from his school,
get the files because it reminds us of earlier in the film,
when Jason Stryker used an illusion of a little girl to mind control Xavier,
the film even refers to both the illusion and the actual student as a little
girl, she's just.
No, she's not.
Like many other X-Men movies.
Xavier's character arc revolves around his ability to nurture younger mutants
and to, because he gets captured,
he's unable to protect his students from the government.
But now,
and then every mother needs to get away without her babies are
helpless.
Mind controls it. Xavier is a former student who'd saved your failed to save.
Jason's a living example of Xavier's fear that he won't be able to help his
students. At this point in the movie,
Xavier can't protect them and he can't use them to do good.
It's actually turned into the opposite. Instead of mentoring students,
a student now mentors, him giving him instructions on what to do.
The whole scene puts it Xavier at his lowest harming mutants instead of
mentoring them. But once he's at the white house, he has repaired his mentor,
student relationships.
He now mentors a little girl from his school to use her powers for the greater
good.
Did you get this? Well, let's just say,
I know a little girl who can walk through walls.
By connecting the Allusionist and this scene with a similar character.
A dialogue shows Xavier has moved on from his failures as a teacher and has
resumed his role as a caring mentor. And even without any dialogue,
the other characters in the scene get their own moments.
Earlier in the film are Rogen Iceman, both wanted superhero uniform.
Why did we get uniforms around order should arrive in a few years.
And by the final scene,
they've already got them showing that they've proved themselves as X-Men.
And it's cool to have Nightcrawler back in the oval office because it reminds us
of the opening of the film when he acted much differently there,
his small back and forth with the president in this scene reminds us that his
character was nothing like the menacing monster from the opening scene in a way,
he gets a small bit of redemption by showing the president his true self,
just like with Logan,
Xavier rogue and Iceman Nightcrawler got a moment in this scene to show his
transformation.
Mike crawlers redemption in the white house signals some broader payoffs in the
story. As a whole,
the film begins with a mutant creating chaos in a United States government
building initiating the tenuous relationship between the mutes and community and
the government in direct contrast to the chaos of the first scene in the white
house. This one,
it feels methodical and exact instead of the camera whipping around in
confusion. It moves slowly into with purpose.
And instead of everyone being thrown around, they are perfectly still.
It brings a sense of conclusion to the tension in the very beginning,
that set off the plot of the film,
but this scene goes even deeper than just this one movie,
the entire franchise of X-Men deals with one central question,
should mutants work with humans or fight against them.
This scene shows a little bit of both Xavier trust, humanity, more than Magneto.
That was the central disagreement of the first X-Men film.
But after the events of this movie,
Xavier has clearly seen the potential danger of the government,
knowing the whereabouts of every mutant. When given the option,
the government lets or try to destroy all mutans and that event changed.
ex-Navy your strategy towards dealing with humans.
You can see his transformation when comparing the white house scene with the
other timing. Xavier froze humans in that earlier scene.
He freezes to stop mutans from using their powers.
And the next time you feel like showing off don't.
This time, he lets the presidency their power.
So ex-Navy your consent a message. So in this scene,
the mutans act a little more like Magneto.
They do show what they're capable of in an intimidating way,
but they still make it clear that they want to use that power.
Mr. President, this is not a threat. This is an opportunity.
In a first for the franchise.
Xavier no longer completely relies on the Goodwill of politicians.
This time he extends an olive branch,
but he also makes sure that the president knows the mutants.
Won't go down without a fight.
We're here to stay. Mr. President, the next move is yours.
Because this scene wrap-up the arcs of individual characters,
but it also wraps up the collective arc of all the mutants,
both in this film and in the film series up to this point,
through their collective struggles,
the mutans learned to no longer hide in the shadows and instead to use their
power for the betterment of themselves, their entire race and humanity.
And after looking at this scene closely,
the influences from the empire strikes back become perfectly clear.
Both films have characters who mature a new cast member who gains the trust of
the group and a mix of uncertainty and hope at the end,
the facts that both these films used a very similar tropes to tell such
different stories, shows the brilliance behind this narrative structure.
They both set up the conflict to give characters their own personal struggles
and then reunite those characters to fill their individual arcs and bring the
entire story to net an X, to manage to back.
A lot of that payoff all at once in one excellent scene, many blockbusters,
including other X-Men films,
set up a SQL by sticking a small teaser into the post credits.
But in this scene X to not only laid the groundwork for a SQL,
but also perfectly wrapped with the conflicts within the characters and the film
itself, based on the presentation of this scene,
it's no surprise that the original X-Men series easily managed storylines for
many characters at once and set the standard for world-building and a large
cinematic universe.
This video is part of the one excellent scene series about the X-Men film
franchise. We all hand picked a scene.
We love from the accident to show what makes these films great.
And for a similar, personal curated experience,
when it comes to exploring more films,
I highly recommend movie movie is a curated streaming service that shows
exceptional films from around the world.
What makes this service stand out is that every day movie presents a new film
hand selected by their team of curators.
So you'll always have something great to watch.
They have tons of timeless classics,
award-winning masterpieces and festival fresh jets, the kinds of films.
I definitely want to watching Maura to start. I'd recommend watching June noon,
a fascinating documentary directed by Paul Thomas Anderson about the making of
the album. June noon, inside of a giant Ford in India,
you can try movie for free for 30 days@movie.com slash. Now you see it.
That's M U B i.com/.
Now you see it for a whole month of great cinema for free,
a big thanks to movie for sponsoring and thanks to you,
our patrons for your support. If you want to support our work directly,
join our Patriots. Thanks for.
Watching.